we've already been introduced to the
chi-squared statistic in other videos
now we're going to use it for a test for
homogeneity and homogeneity or
homogeneity in everyday language this
means how similar things are and that's
what we're essentially going to test
here we're going to look at two
different groups and see whether the
distributions of those groups for a
certain variable are similar or not and
so the question i'm going to think about
or we're going to think about together
in this video is
let's say we were thinking about
left-handed versus right-handed people
and we're wondering do they have the
same preferences for subject domains are
they equally inclined to science
technology engineering math humanities
or neither and so we can set up our null
and alternative hypotheses our null
hypothesis is that there is no
difference in the distribution between
left-handed and right-handed people in
terms of their preference for subject
domains so
no
difference
in
subject
subject preference
for left and right for
left
and right
handed
folks and then the alternative
hypothesis well no there is a difference
so
there
is
a
difference
so how would we go about testing this
well we've done hypothesis testing many
times in many videos already but here
we're going to sample from two different
groups so let's say that this is the
population of
right-handed folks
and this is the population of
left-handed folks
let's say from that sample of
right-handed folks i take a sample of 60
and then i do the same thing for the
left-handed folks and these don't even
have to be the same sample sizes so the
left-handed folks let's say i sample 40
folks
and here is the data that i actually
collect
so for those 60 right-handed folks 30 of
them prefer to prefer the stem subjects
science technology engineering math 15
preferred humanities and 15 were
indifferent they liked them equally
and then for the 40 left-handed folks i
got 10 preferring stem 25 preferring
humanities and five viewed them equally
and then you see the total number of
right-handed folks total number of
left-handed folks and then you have the
total number from both groups that
preferred stem total number from both
groups that preferred humanities total
number from both groups that had no
preference so let's just start thinking
about what the expected data would be if
we're assuming that the null hypothesis
is true that there's no difference in
preference between right and left-handed
folks this is the right-handed
column this is the left-handed column
well assuming that the null hypothesis
is true that there's no difference
between right and left-handed people in
terms of their preference our best
estimate of what the distribution of
preference would be in the population
generally would come from this total
column
since we're assuming no difference we
would assume that in either group 40 out
of every 100 would prefer stem or 40
percent 40 percent would prefer
humanities and 20 percent would have no
preference and so our expected would be
that forty percent of the sixty
right-handed folks would prefer stem so
what's forty percent of sixty point four
times sixty is twenty four and similarly
we would expect 40
preferring humanities 40
times 60 is 24 again and then we would
expect 20 of the right-handed group to
have no preference so 20 of 60 is
12. and these once again they add up to
60 and then for the left-handed folks we
would go through the same process we
would expect that 40 percent of them
prefer stem forty percent of forty that
is sixteen on the humanities again forty
percent of forty is sixteen
and equal twenty percent of forty is
eight and then all of these add up to
forty once you calculate these expected
values it's a good time to make sure
you're meeting your conditions for
conducting a chi-squared test the first
is the random condition and so these
need to be truly random samples so
hopefully we met that condition the
second is that the expected value for
any of these data points have to be at
least equal to five and so we have met
that condition these are all at least
equal to five and then the last
condition is the independence condition
that we are either sampling with
replacement or if we're not sampling
with replacement we have to feel good
that our samples are no more than 10
percent of the population so let's
assume that that is the case as well
and now we're ready to calculate our chi
squared statistic
we would get our chi squared statistic
is going to be equal to the difference
between what we got
and the expected squared so 30 minus 24
squared divided by the expected divided
by 24 and we'll do it for all six of
these data points so then i will go to
the next one so then this is going to be
so plus and if i look at this and this
here i'm going to have
minus 16
squared
over
expected 16.
and then i'm going to have i would look
at that data point and that expected and
i would get 15 minus 24
squared over expected over 24.
i'm running out of colors and then we
would look at that those two numbers and
we would say plus 25 minus 16 squared
divided by expected and then we would
get
we would look at these two
plus
15 minus 12
squared
over expected over 12. and then last but
not least let me find a color i haven't
used
we would look at that and that and we
would say plus 5
minus 8 squared over expected over 8.
now once you get that value for the
chi-square statistic the next question
is what are the degrees of freedom now a
simple rule of thumb is to just look at
your data and think about the number of
rows and the number of columns and we
have three rows and two columns and so
your degrees of freedom are going to be
the number of rows minus one three minus
one times the number of columns minus
one two minus 1. and so this is going to
be equal to 2 times 1 which is equal to
2. now the reason why that makes
intuitive sense is think about it if you
knew two of these data points and if you
knew all of the totals then you could
figure out the other data points if you
knew these two data points you could
figure out that if you knew this data
point you knew the total you could
point and you knew the total you could
figure out that and if you if you
figured out that and that then you could
figure out this right over here and so
that's why this rule of thumb works the
number of rows minus 1 times the number
of columns minus 1 gives you your
degrees of freedom
now given this chi-squared statistic
that i haven't calculated but you could
type this into a calculator and figure
it out and this degrees of freedom we
could then figure out the p-value we
could figure out the probability of
getting a chi-squared statistic this
extreme or more extreme and if this is
less than our significance level which
we should have set ahead of time then we
would reject the null hypothesis and it
would suggest the alternative if this is
not less than our significance level
then it does not allow us to reject the
null hypothesis